all state series of mayhem commercials
is one of the most successful ad
campaigns in recent memory that's easy
to understand why they've caught on
I'm your phone stuck down here between
your seat and your console playing a
little hide-and-seek
if you've watched these spots and felt
like the guy playing mayhem seems
familiar you're right he popped up in a
number of shows and films over the last
couple of decades
here are some surprising facts you
didn't know about all states mayhem man
Dean winters a guy walks into a bar
Winters landed his first movie role in
the 1997 Mel Gibson and Julia Roberts
thriller conspiracy theory but that
wasn't winters first screen acting gig
overall in the 1995 TV season he had a
recurring role as Tom Moran's on NBC's
acclaimed police drama homicide life on
the street he got that part via his
connection with homicide creator and
producer Tom Fontana up to that point
winters had primarily paid the bills
with a bartending job in New York City
Fontana walked into winters Upper East
Side bar at about 2:00 a.m. one night
and the two struck up a friendship
fontana offered to write a role into the
show for winters and eventually he
accepted it turned into a good decision
for the young actor when Fontana moved
on to create the prison drama Oz for HBO
he wrote the role of Ryan O'Reily
specifically for winters 30 rock runaway
for viewers of the Tina Fey sitcom 30
rock winters will always be Dennis Duffy
Liz Lemon sleazy on-again off-again
boyfriend it's a fancy briefcase sale
because you're classy and important like
a dude Thank You Dennis Duffy's many
quirks made him a fan favorite but he
almost didn't get the gig winters later
said I went to audition for 30 rock I
walked in and there was like 30 guys up
there reading for my role and they were
the funniest guys in New York City faced
with that level of talented competition
winters bolted when his talent agency
found out about it they issued an
ultimatum go back to the audition or
they drop him as a client
needless to say winters went back and
got the gig
guess what are you doing I'm gonna not a
TV on your watch just can't find stud he
actually died one morning in June 2009
winters a wolf with a fever and stayed
in bed all day the next morning he went
to his doctor's office and that's where
he collapsed he later told page six I
was turning black and my whole head was
swelling up an ambulance raced winters
to the hospital but on the way his heart
stopped for two and a half minutes
paramedics revived him and he wound up
spending three weeks in intensive care
to recover from a bacterial infection
Winters was too sick to work for a year
right before his brush with mortality
he'd filmed a pilot for an ABC show
called happy town and when it was picked
up producers replaced him
however exactly one year and a day after
he collapsed his best-known work hit
screens when Allstate launched its mr.
mayhem campaign avoiding mayhem winters
almost didn't live to make those mayhem
ads and in fact he almost didn't appear
in them at all after his medical
nightmare he had to relearn how to walk
he explained I was feeling sorry for
myself I had lost toes and half a thumb
and the tip of my nose fell off and this
nurse took me to the Children's burn
unit I saw these eight kids with
prosthetic legs playing soccer and I
thought that's it that's the moment when
I turned everything around and decided
to learn how to walk again
when Allstate Insurance sought him out
to play the mayhem guy in its huge
commercial campaign winters turned them
down at first he told HuffPost live when
they offered me the commercial I said no
my smartass remark was that I became an
actor so I wouldn't have to put on a
suit and sell insurance and then my
agent slapped me around and said come on
get real active career shooting a string
of 30-second TV commercials is Dean
winters most widely known gig but it
leaves him enough time to do lots of
acting in movies and on TV shows where
you often play street smart tough guys
and cops since the mayhem campaign began
in 2010 winters surfaced on sitcoms like
Brooklyn nine-nine and divorce in
addition to his recurring roles on 30
rock Rescue Me and Law & Order SVU
Winters also starred on Battle Creek a
short-lived CBS crime drama Dee
co-created by Breaking Bad's Vince
Gilligan winters has also appeared in
films like John wick horror [ __ ] as a
young man Dean winters wrote him
an acting bucket list of all different
kinds of projects he aimed to perform in
someday he later recalled I was like I
want to be in a horror film I want to be
in a Western I want to be in this I want
to be in that one item winters can cross
off that list is a horror movie winter's
played a sleazy businessman morning his
wife and dealing with amnesia in the
2002 direct-to-video release Hellraiser
hell seeker the sixth film in the series
featuring the spiky headed pinhead it
wasn't necessarily a dream come true
however in fact winters didn't have the
best time shooting the movie he
explained I took that movie at the last
minute I got to Vancouver and if there
were 120 scenes in the movie I think I
was in 116 and I got sick like at the
end of the first read-through winters
wound up being extremely ill for three
weeks out of the four weeks shoot and it
didn't help that the film was shot in a
real psychiatric facility he added I was
having nightmares and seeing visions in
the hospital it was just bananas the
hands of mayhem the Leo Burnett
advertising agency conceived of the
mayhem ads and in 2011 Burnett executive
vice president Nina Abney unequivocally
told Ad Age that one of the inspirations
behind mayhem was simple saying we
wanted to kick Flo's ass she's speaking
of course about all state rival
progressives extremely popular
advertising mascot thanks in part to the
flow ad onslaught all states market
share dropped for two straight years the
mayhem campaign reversed all states
fortunes with winters character and an
emphasis on value over price
[Applause]